so this is just a quick one off video
about a turbo runabout design which I
shared yesterday but didn't actually
share how I made it at all and my acid
editor isn't working and I don't quite
want to find out it's how I can get it
to work and what more is causing it and
really for my own convenience it's easy
to make this video here I do need to
give quick credits to d3 constructor
made another similar version of a turbo
roundabout nearly a year ago but it
doesn't actually use the tools that we
have today like wrote anarchy and
precision tools using which you can get
so much more precise and realistic with
the turbo roundabouts
in any case if you want to build a
roundabouts there's one important
question I want to ask which is why
because actually in the game it doesn't
work as well as it could in real life in
real life they are have a higher
capacity and they are more safe than
regular roundabouts but in the game I've
tested a cup of them and none of them
really seem to function better than just
a simple round about with highways in
the game since the AI just doesn't like
them too much there's also some issues
with glitching crosswalks so you need to
get some different mods for that and
essentially you can make a similar type
thing if you use Traffic Manager or
traffic plus plus to change the lanes
regardless though I still need to make
this quick tutorial especially if you
want to go for a turbo roundabouts
design for aesthetics or just because
you want to have something which just a
little bit more fancy than your regular
roundabouts highway and also if you're
making a Dutch city and you really want
to go completely realistic this might
help out a lot ok so to start it just
want to start off with a quick straight
road like that as an entrance and have a
2x2 curve a 4x4 curve and another 4x4
curve and just leave it just like that
and I want to use the one lane and
one-way roads just because they're quite
small I'll upgrade them to two-lane
one-way roads later on just to look a
little bit better but for the time being
these are easier to
I know and also on the other side you're
going to do exactly the same just the
other way around
so gonna come down from above here and
go into this direction and have a 2x2
curve here a 4x4 curve here and another
4x4 curve over here and out of the
roundabouts and this is basically the
basic spiral structure of a turbo
runabout where you start off if you go
from here to here on the inner circle of
the roundabouts but you sort of spiral
into the outer circle up to the points
where you want to get off and this is
very much the basic structure and from
this points you actually want to very
quickly start upgrading these roads
before we go any further and that has to
do with the fact that it's very it's
impossible to actually make the
connection between two roads over here
over just one tile if you already have
the two-lane roads so we're going to
have to upgrade this before we get to
that so I want to upgrade this curve
first and this curve too and don't worry
about these not being possible because
you can really just add a quick straight
road over here and that does work though
a quick thing to note about this this
only really works if you have sharp
Junction angles and you press ctrl a and
control B to make sure to respectively
get rid of all the what they call it
anarchy so you can pretty much do
anything you want with control a and
control B will prevent snapping to
certain curves when you connect roads to
each other okay so now the next thing we
want to do is just very quickly put a
road in between these this will make
sure that the shape of this won't
distort as we add the connections and we
just want to connect another road over
here make sure it does face the right
direction and same for the other side so
one road over here whoops there we go
and reverse it and that should be good
as the entrance and exits on both the
north and the south side of it and at
this point you can also upgrade these
roads already which will make sure that
you don't get awkward to drop our cross
glitches in the middle of the
roundabouts now the sides are both a
little
to connect and the only way to actually
get it working is to connect a small
road over here and make sure it's
connected here so you have an extra node
and you can see a distorting little
there and it's not a perfect circle but
you really need that slight distortion
over there to actually be able to
connect roads to it in the future
because if that node isn't there you
won't be able to connect a very small
connection between where this road is
going to end eventually and same goes
for this road you'll see it in a second
basically so now it should look like
this
and we're going to want to upgrade these
roads on the side to two-lane roads and
connect them to the end and this will be
the most outer lane for the entire round
about and really finish the shape of it
and now we can just connect these roads
on the sides over here and basically
because we added that extra nodes in the
middle of this extra node in the middle
over here you can connect this over very
short distance of just two squares and
if you didn't add that node over there
you won't be able to actually make that
connection okay so pretty much after
upgrading all of the roads this is what
the finished turbo roundabout should
look like the only issue really well
there's a couple of issues that I do
have with it if you have network skins
it would be a pretty good help to turn
off the street lights because as you can
see they go pretty mad on a turbo
roundabout like this and since it's also
larger than its real-life counterparts
except for the ones with traffic lights
you might just want to put a couple of
street lights as props in between it but
that's going too far into beautification
also I forgot I wrote over here that's
pretty stupid a one major issue with
this as you can see is the glitching of
crosswalks it's pretty bad not to
mention that this looks a whole lot
better without all of the crosswalks so
if you do have one of the traffic
managers it would probably be a lot
better to get rid of all the crosswalks
though of course that's just optional
and you can always just build it with
the network's network extensions second
highway yeah all of the crosswalks
aren't entirely beautiful another thing
to note about this is that if you really
want to get that touch sort of thing
what you quite often see a
is that it's turbo roundabouts I really
just connected to two-lane roads which
go in both ways but the roads have to
split as they approach the roundabouts
so will you quite often see actually and
a quick way to do that is that the
regular road splits into two one-way
roads and you can just kind of very
quickly recreate that sort of idea by
adding a small grid over here and
connecting these roads to make sure they
and at exactly these same spots I got
that can be kind of hard to do though
there we go and what I commonly like to
do for this type of case is you can
create a road just about here and use
the one way one lane roads to connect it
to both of these roads like this and
make sure they are facing the right
direction and you'll have a quick
transition so especially if you're in a
rural area or an industry area and you
do have some one lane roads especially
since turbo roundabouts are quite often
used for a place where a very busy road
crosses a less busy road it can be quite
handy to use this thing on the side and
of course too for you traffic managers
out there there's one issue which has to
do with the fact that especially the
outer lanes for just making a quarter
turn or quite often just completely
skipped by these city skylines car users
and instead they'll just go into the
center lane and go in from here so
especially for cases like that it can be
very handy to actually change the lanes
and say for cases like this you can only
go straight and you can only go to the
side which is what I would really
recommend to change if you have either
one of the traffic managers or traffic
plus plus b2 so I quickly built a city
of about 4,000 people and a lot of
Industry and commercial zones just to
see how well it really does work and
it's sort of very evenly spread among
all four directions in this case the top
one is the one coming in from
the regions and while it does take all
of the traffic reasonably well it
actually doesn't take it as well as a
possible four lane or three lane highway
roundabout word that you can just build
in city skyline so yes well it is
something that you can build for realism
or just aesthetic purposes it doesn't
really live up to its other versions
since as you can see over here the three
lane roundabouts actually has kissed
about as good as the capacity as the
turbo roundabout has in the same space
if not better the only real difference
that I can really find here is that the
regular two lane roundabouts gets
absolutely annihilated by all of the
traffic which at least it turbo run
about dozens but yeah if you're looking
to actually use this turbo roundabout or
some variation on it I would say there
are definitely better options out there
if you wanna get a congestion free city
and it's really just for the aesthetics
or to mess with the idea of making a
turbo roundabouts and there are really
some core issues in the game that
prevents it from actually working very
well in this case among which the fact
that this is quite a oversized
roundabout for turbo roundabouts they
are not usually made with two lane lanes
like this but just much smaller versions
that sort of replace a regular one lane
roundabouts which they they do have a
higher capacity than regular one lane
roundabouts but you can't really get
them in in that space in the game and
it's really nearly impossible to make
them much smaller than this one
currently is and another issue with this
is that turbo roundabouts are really
designed around well real people driving
real cars and in the game you don't
really have this safety aspect or the
idea that's conflict points will lead to
more crashes and more congestion because
it just doesn't really work that way too
much and real life trouble roundabouts
are really used to get rid of all of the
conflict points that you have on a
regular multi-lane roundabout
you have to get on it and make sure you
get through the outer lane and then find
yourself one of the inner more lanes if
you want to make like a 3/4 turn and
then as you want to leave the
roundabouts you need to find your way
into the outer Lane again and make your
way through it's to actually get to your
destination where you want to go whereas
in a real turbo runabout you should have
enter it and then you just spiral to the
side of it without having any conflict
points or too many places where you need
to keep track of other cars or you need
to try to join other lanes because you
simply don't really have to do so and
this is an idea that while Sims and sim
Edward it had just called SimCity Sims
in city skylines just don't really care
abouts and there's also the idea that
people like to implement about
roundabouts because they're safer and
generally they are thoughtfully - less
accidents but yeah there is no reason to
really care about that in city skylines
I suppose so yeah it's just for
aesthetics I suppose or if you really
want to make that touch city or if
you're just crazy about roundabouts
anyway thank you for watching and hope
you at least picked up something from
this random video